to the girl on Facebook who commented
hashtag all lives matter folks in the US
and around the world have watched
Ferguson Missouri in shock now it had
yester lone station in Hungary and these
hundreds of refugees they've been on
this road in September 5th is now
September 15th here in New Orleans and
it's been 10 years since Hurricane
Katrina California's largest inland body
of water used to cover where I'm
standing
foreign parents were world leaders of
the UN climate conflict so we were just
visiting the asylum center that you were
living in these days is a lot easier and
takes fewer people to spy on one person
or spy on everyone without matter you
know everybody loves your neighborhood
teacher but no one wants to pony up to
pay us a salary
my father was reported when I was in
10th grade
I'm a billionaire and as part of the 1%
how can you possibly represent let alone
relate to the remaining 99% of America
our relation to socialism is a dirty
word in American politics
it's lobbed at presidents to try and
tear them down and use my outsiders to
set them apart you put your name on this
they're going to destroy you
you